The Disney+ original series The Mandalorian
is a massive hit, and its fans have about
a million questions about the series' breakout
star.
We're not entirely sure what the deal with
Baby Yoda is, but here's everything we know
so far.
Yoda's species is extremely mysterious: George
Lucas famously never gave it a name, wishing
the wizened Jedi Master to remain an enigma
in as many ways as possible.
One thing we do know, however, is that members
of this race are not asexual, as illustrated
by Star Wars Episode I: The Phantom Menace.
That film gave us a few fleeting glimpses
of Yaddle, a female member of Yoda's species
who was a member of the Jedi High Council
and even assisted in the training of a young
Qui-Gon Jinn.
While The Mandalorian doesn't go out of its
way to clue us in as to the gender of Baby
Yoda, Doctor Pershing, an employee of the
Client, reveals the truth in the series' third
episode.
"What did you do to it?"
"I protected him!
I protected him!
If it wasn't for me, he'd already be dead!"
And the little tyke is referred to as "he"
several times in episode 4, and Omera even
calls him the Mandolorian's "boy."
So at least one mystery has been solved for
sure: Baby Yoda's a baby boy!
With that out of the way, let's move on to
a question that might sound silly at first:
Is "Baby Yoda" actually the Yoda we all know
and love?
After all, the Jedi Master was a baby once,
and it would certainly explain the little
guy's importance to the remnants of the Empire
and the Rebellion alike.
Of course, giving this question a few moments'
thought produces an obvious answer: no way.
At least, not unless Yoda's species practices
reincarnation.
The Mandalorian takes place between the events
of the original Star Wars trilogy and the
sequel films, and you may remember that Yoda
"became one with the Force" and died during
the events of Return of the Jedi.
While we suppose it's possible that the series
could throw us a curveball with an "actual
Yoda in an infant's body" reveal, nothing
in the show's plotting thus far indicates,
to be frank, that it would take a route that's
quite so lazy.
No, we're pretty sure that a new character
Baby Yoda is; the reincarnation of Yoda, he
is not.
Of course, there is another possibility: that
Baby Yoda could be a clone of the late Jedi
Master.
It's been pointed out by astute fans that
in a promotional image featuring Doctor Pershing,
he appears to be wearing a patch with an insignia
that is very, very similar to those worn by
the clones of Jango Fett produced on the planet
Kamino, as seen in Attack of the Clones.
This could be a coincidence, it could be misdirection,
or, it could be a dead giveaway.
Of course, if the little dude isn't Yoda,
this raises the question: what is his name?
Yes, we can all be pretty sure that the internet
would have initially named him "Baby Yoda"
in any event, but it only continues to do
so because we haven't been clued in to what
his real name is...have we?
The answer: no, we have not.
According to Dave Filoni, who directed the
first and fifth episodes of The Mandalorian's
first season, this is by design.
Speaking with Entertainment Tonight, Filoni
said,
"We still want to keep a lot of things a mystery,
we don't want to go around answering things
and making them less special."
Told that people were simply referring to
the tot as "Baby Yoda" for lack of anything
else to call him, Filoni replied, quote, "That's
fine!
All part of the mystery."
Well, that clears up nothing, but since we
haven't even gotten official confirmation
of the Mandalorian's name yet, we suppose
that shouldn't be too surprising.
One of the most dramatic moments in The Mandalorian
so far came in the second episode, when "Mando"
is nearly killed by a vicious Mudhorn.
Wielding nothing but a knife, the Mandalorian
lowers his head as the beast charges, but
the charge is interrupted by Baby Yoda, who
uses the Force to levitate the snarling monster,
allowing the Mandalorian to finish it off.
So, how the heck is an infant able to use
the Force?
Doesn't that require super-intensive training?
Well...yes and no.
Don't forget that, as revealed by The Phantom
Menace, children can indeed be Force-sensitive,
and tap into its power, with little-to-no
training.
Consider Anakin Skywalker, whose status as
one of the best pod racers in the galaxy as
a mere youngling was thanks to his insane
midichlorian count, "even higher than Master
Yoda," as we recall Obi-Wan Kenobi saying.
Sure, Anakin wasn't levitating stuff as a
child, but we find it highly likely that members
of Yoda's species are naturally Force-sensitive,
taking into account that the only two to be
introduced prior to Baby Yoda's arrival were
both esteemed Jedi Masters.
Until The Mandalorian gives us a better explanation
for the little guy's Force abilities, anyway,
that's the best one we've got.
With the release of Star Wars Episode IX:
The Rise of Skywalker swiftly approaching,
fans have obviously taken to wondering if
the cute and cuddly character's introduction
in The Mandalorian is setting us up for an
appearance in the Skywalker Saga's conclusion.
Since the series takes place some time before
the events of the sequel trilogy, it could
be that by the time of the events of Rise
of Skywalker, Baby Yoda would be...well, we're
not sure.
Kid Yoda?
Tween Yoda, perhaps?
Old enough, at any rate, to potentially play
a key part in the story.
However, we find this to be highly unlikely.
There's no evidence that The Mandalorian's
creator and lead writer, Jon Favreau, has
coordinated in any way, shape, or form with
Skywalker writer/director J.J. Abrams, and
a Young Yoda cameo, while likely a crowd-pleaser,
would be off-the-charts distracting, not to
mention shoehorned in, considering what we
know about the plot of Skywalker.
No, we're thinking that Baby Yoda will be
a character specific to The Mandalorian, and
that's just fine by us.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Mandalorian
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.